indians are going to turn to eli morgan
into 25 year old he'll be making his
second start
now the 0-2 swing and a miss talking
about a change-up
that one was 76 miles an hour and badly
fooled mullins
trey mancini oh my goodness it hit
morgan
and it carries right to chang for the
out well let's see if morgan's okay i
don't know where it got him
boy that did uh that got back in a hurry
right above the elbow there my goodness
and they're gonna stay with him for now
he knows he's got it
out that thing went up in the air and he
was able to catch it morgan says i'm
okay tito and the one-two
spoiled it over toward the indians
dugout he's saying it was catcher's
interference
i thought he said he hit the catcher's
club it did that's catcher's
interference
he just almost knocked the glove off his
hand it is catcher's interference
no he is awarded first base two down for
anthony santander
2-1 pitch popped in the air shallow
right backpedaling is ernie clement
fighting the sun makes the grab and the
side is retired
jorge lopez taking them out second start
that he has made against cleveland
this year 2-2 here is seared to third
caught by franco
110 miles per hour was off the line
and while zimmer stung it franco made a
diving catch
to get jorge lopez a much deserved first
out
jose ramirez 3-0 pitch he launches one
high in the air
deep right field santa dare wave goodbye
green means go
two-nothing cleveland bobby bradley
bobby sends one to center that's well
struck cedric's looking up it is
gone a home run bobby bradley
booms one to the bleachers and it's
three to nothing cleveland
here comes manager brandon hyde he's
going to claim that the fan
reached over the railing and interfered
with the ball and that's a homer here we
go eli morgan
is back out here and on a one-two fly
ball from hayes high and deep to left
field get out of here
austin hayes a crusher deep into the
seats and left
number six for hayes and the o's are on
the board
in a major way
swing and a miss threw a good fastball
down and away
gets his second strikeout one down here
in the second
two gone for austin wins here in the
second forum
through it by him upstairs a high
fastball his third strike
up brian mount castle whom the indians
can't get out
steps to the plate it's a swing and a
miss from ryan mount castle and he
strikes it out for route number two
where the way he's been swinging at that
is a big out for the young right hand
with a three to one lead and here's
anthony santander
santander lifts a fly ball left field
eddie on the run
makes the catch just shy of the wall and
hangs on to retire the sides
here's eddie rosario still doesn't have
a home run of progressive field this
year
and eddie rocks at the deep right field
this one is gone to souvenir city
another 02 pitch yeah that one
blasted out of here well i think that
lopez wanted this ball back as soon as
he released it
he tried to throw the fastball by him
and it's right down
the center of the plate so one down and
that'll bring up michael franco
oh one pitch franco swings a deep drive
out towards left field this ball is up
off the top of the wall
michael franco picks up the team
cuts the lead in half 4-2
and the orioles are loving left field
here comes tito and he's not going to
let
morgan face this lineup the third time
around
so he goes three and two-thirds innings
now kyle nelson the left-hander coming
on trey mancini the batter
inside pitch trey pops it up right field
long run for naylor with a hat off but
it drops in
wins will score mullins will get to
third
it's a well-placed rbi single for trey
and the o's are within one a two run
fourth inning and counting
here's hugh chang there's a hard hit
ball but
a nice play by franco they get one
and they turn the double play to end the
inning
let's see if the indians take a look and
he wants to hear it they're gonna check
oh man that's really close but i think
he did beat it headsets are off
safe at first base ernie clements
swats one deep left field and it is off
the wall
flying around third they're gonna wave
chang home here's the throw to the plane
he is
say ernie clement with his first big
league rbi his first
double and you chang with an all-out
hustle play scores
from first base i mean that was tough to
pick it both ways
and get him so very aggressive he's safe
they get a run
and make it a 5-3 game here comes
michael franco
boy there's a bloop shot coming in right
field a sliding catch by naylor
he's done it again that's the second
time i think in this series we've seen
him make an almost identical play
in right field where he came racing in
sliding and held on trevor stefan the
third indians pitcher to work today 3-2
pitch again
swing and a miss he stayed right with
him and a good fastball down at the
knees from
trevor stefan to strike him out one away
swag and a miss he went fishing came up
empty third strikeout
for trevor stefan two down josh naylor's
grounded out and walked
there's a ball hit the left center field
that's in the alley that'll split him
and go to the wall
levard way lumbering into third he'll be
held there by mike sarbaugh
hold up and the orioles catch a break
that he stopped him because the
relay thrown over the head of the cutoff
man but the indians have second and
third and nobody out
but he's gonna chase salsa after uh uh
back-to-back hits
dylan tate coming on right-hander
against right-hander chang
for two and it's swung out and looped
into center that's a base hit
it'll score levinway naylor's being
waved home as well
big two-run single to center by
well he wastes no time took advantage of
the infield being in
put a nice stroke on it into center
field and get
two homes the fourth pitcher to work for
the indians today
got him breaking ball adam frozen at the
dish trey mancini out looking one down
here's freddy galvez down the one-two
elvis waves at it struck him out good
slider
so henches has struck out one with a
slider and one with a curveball
and here's anthony santander 2-2 pitch
got a piece that he held on nice job by
lavon wade
and a strikeout for inches indians with
a seven to three lead and you change the
battery
whoa blast off
deep onto the home run porch what a day
for chang
on two run homer give him four runs
batted in on the afternoon what a ball
game for you change
nick woodgrain will try to close it out
rails are down to their last out
and a fly ball to left eddie is there
book it the indians sweep the four game
series from the birds